you do that to me
get out of here
get out of here
[Music]
hey i'm jeremiah watkins and i'm here to
answer the internet
uh if your arms were spaghetti would you
want them to be cooked or uncooked i
would want them to be uh cooked for sure
because the spaghetti noodles break so
easily if they're uncooked that i would
be like running into stuff and then like
i'd have no arms what if they were right
if they were like as thick as your arms
are there so there was sturdiness but
they were just like
oh and then you wouldn't have to worry
about them breaking bubbles oh dude
popping and walking just like that
yeah yeah i mean you'd have to be a
dancer at that point like that's your
profession
that's your only option yeah is sex with
conjoined twins a threesome uh
there's a lot of factors there because
is the other person
partaking or are they on the other side
of the bed
like wanting in you know what i mean
like are they hanging off the side of
the bed also having sex with a conjoined
twin is that right
that's the real question
[Laughter]
would you rather get caught masturbating
or [ __ ] your pants in public
[ __ ] for sure
the way this is phrased is like like you
just masturbate you can do that in
public like do you ever just see a guy
just like in full clothing i mean we're
in new york bro i mean i've seen it on
bus benches in l.a and stuff like that i
mean the pooping is one of those things
where it's like
i think we've all been there
i've seen my pants in public on
[Laughter]
[Music]
would you go to a football game at a 70
000 seat stadium if you knew that 500
seats would get ejected into a black
hole but everyone who didn't get ejected
would get five million dollars i think i
might go to that those are good those
are those are pretty good
yeah those are pretty good odds i mean
it would freak you out that your best
friend next to you gets launched yeah if
you found a porn online of your buddy
and his girlfriend would you watch it
would you say anything to him
i'd probably watch it
it's do they know that they put that out
if they didn't know that it was the kind
of person who didn't know that it was
out then i'd be like dude i think like
something weird dude yeah
sex tape kind of friend you'd let him go
you know yeah that's kind of fun
i just gotta you know check out for
friendship
[Laughter]
would you rather
watch your dad [ __ ] a hundred year old
man or b watch your mother kill someone
oh i'm watching my mom kill somebody for
sure sure almost universally she loves
murder shows she'll get to live out one
of her fantasies that every woman wants
to live out
is it my mom's birthday this is great
i love it i love it i want to see my mom
kiss her
would you rather be blind or [ __ ]
blind blind is the worst being blind
sucks have you seen daredevil my dick
senses would be heightened
my dick sense would be like oh the the
coming and everything would feel even
better that's how that works right you
could just be a blind guy coming
everywhere yeah that's that would be my
life in jail you'd be a deviant no
no i'd be like a circus act like that
guy comes alive
you know it's like oh [ __ ] oh what's up
no no no no no no no how dare you you
don't do that to me you introduced to me
japan how dare you come on into
champion you don't do that to me
get out of here
get out of here
you try to slam me
i'd answer the internet it's not
happening you see i went to town on him
airing guy beats jew that's the headline
in this video
[Laughter]
watch out
the dicks are smacked in here
[Laughter]
would you rather everyone be naked all
the time or clothed all the time i think
i think clothed all the time i think
they're fat you're anti-fat aren't you
jeremiah
if you've seen anything from this
episode right here i've answered the
internet i don't like jews or fat people
that's that's what you all that you need
to know about me
thanks kevin thanks a lot for the setup
on that
i think clothe i think it's important
for other men to not know other men's
dick sizes at all points because
you can't respect certain people who are
above you like
in jobs and stuff like that or even even
in life if your dad had a way smaller
penis with you if your boss had a way
smaller penis than you i think there
wouldn't be that respect level there's
mystery you guys could be working with
average hogs or huge ones and i respect
you right now if you pulled it down
right now uh i don't know why that's my
only respect thing level i don't know
the more i talk i'm like what are you
talking about
you gotta have a big gift for me to
respect you dude that's what we're
trying to say here okay
would you rather be an extremely good
looking paralyzed person or a hideous
fully functioning person
oh man um i
i think extremely good looking paralyzed
person because
because you know dumbledore's either
choose fats
jews hats argos get them out
i've never known what it feels like to
be an extremely good looking person so
i think that that would be interesting
i'm a fully functioning
kind of weird looking man i know what
that's like
i'd rather be freaking suave brad pitt
in a wheelchair having people pamper me
they'll be excited they'll be stoked to
take care of you and help you out dude
that sympathy paralyzed person
come on
all right big thanks for watching ati
anybody else who you want to see any up
and coming comics anybody who you think
deserves to be a superstar comment below
we'll go get em make sure you subscribe
to the channel right now